the jurogan experience
the thing that you find over time is
that people understand you like they'll
watch your podcast with andrew and
they've seen you guys for hundreds of
hours yes they know you right so like
when you're talking if you say something
if you misstep or
you know if you say something that
doesn't turn out to be that they know
what you're trying to do they know
you're not a vicious person you're just
trying to be funny and you're never
gonna be perfect uh this is the biggest
opportunity in my life i'm gonna walk
out here being like i wish i said that
one thing differently of course yeah did
you take any [ __ ] like that you have
this defense of apu which is a [ __ ]
hilarious bit thank you so much man
thank you it's so dead-on i appreciate
it's like why is that offensive why is
that guy offensive does anybody give you
a hard time about that i'm getting some
comments and what i want to delineate i
think is the word like differentially
delineate thank you i'm not as smart as
i should be but what i want to
differentiate is the difference between
your hurt feelings and being oppressed
your hurt feelings are valid and if kids
kids made fun of me for it that's valid
that hurt i can go talk to a therapist
but you're not [ __ ] oppressed and
that's what i thought canceling a pool
was it was we think we're oppressed and
we're not at all with that [ __ ] well
there's a lot of things going on right
like first of all there's a white guy
doing the voice yeah what's that dude's
name henry azaria the [ __ ] hank zarya
right yeah that's my guy bruh he was on
uh what else was he on oh he's done
accident he's in everything he's been a
bunch of he didn't have shows he does a
hilarious french accent and along came
poly that's so over the top and so
ridiculous but it's so funny he's a guy
that just does accents well you're
allowed to do french people though yeah
because it's like they don't have extra
melanin they don't have extra melanin
and i see how it's worse but i also what
that this guy the voice yeah yeah yeah
yeah dude that's so [ __ ] funny are
you for scuba yeah
yes dude it's so funny
what is that movie along came polly it's
a it's a movie most people hate but i
love it's one of those romantic comedies
jennifer anderson ben stiller but he was
wasn't he in a sitcom he's in oh for
sure probably he's in everything
i just thought i had i understand the
context with which the simpsons was
created it was a show that came out in
the late 80s i didn't know any indian
actors much less voice over actors to do
that voice so he did it and then he
brought it to life
and i looked at the simpsons and i said
this is the most three-dimensional
supporting character on that entire show
everybody else is ecstatic chief wiggum
is static mo is completely static
barney's a drunk loser all the time
a pooh is like three-dimensional and he
evolves more than every character on
that show including the simpsons he gets
married he loses a business gains a
business has kids becomes a father so
like i love that story that's a
beautiful story he's the american dream
on that show have they completely
removed him from the show he's gone from
the show
and i think it's [ __ ] because dude a
poo if it was voiced by a brown person a
poo is so many of our parents and i
don't mean that and i mean in the most
respectful way like i used to always
hear um back in the heyday people would
say the simpsons represents every level
of society that's why the politician is
a sleazebag and the billionaire is a
corrupt [ __ ] and a poo i really thought
whether they meant to or not represented
the american dream he came to this
country in search of a better life he
worked hard he was mostly honorable and
he built a [ __ ] life and that is our
parents and we should all be so proud of
our parents and it sucks that a white
guy was doing the voice but at the time
i don't think they had an option he's
doing 12 voices they just threw him one
extra they didn't have a budget and then
he made it something so i would say some
of the jokes were a little hacky you can
evolve those but you don't get rid of
the guy completely it's an over
correction